hello everyone and welcome back to some
more rapid action unleashes last game I
was able to win even though I blundered
a rook at my opponent's last second but
he didn't uh have um even enough time to
capture my Rook which was fortunate for
me uh but uh yeah I'm I'm um Trying to
minimize these blunders but it's not
easy to do when you get into time
trouble uh you know crazy stuff happens
but this game I have decided this game I
will be playing fast moves and correct
moves now let's see if that is possible
and hopefully I don't played the worst
game so far in the series so let's
create a game uh and 10 minutes per
player here we go uh our opponent is
let's check it out probably we get the
white pieces but maybe we get two black
in row uh who
knows uh no we get white and our
opponent is cppy 48 rated 2419 so quite
the opponent for my uh for my Saturday's
decision of playing precise moves while
I'm doing it fast okay he's going to go
for what he's going to go for the uh for
the E6 Sicilian and he will probably
punish us dearly here but yeah let's do
it uh let's go Bishop to
E2 uh he wants to capture this Pawn
so yeah that's uh also that's very nice
I'm going to capture here since I don't
know how to play this line and uh yeah
ask him to show me
what what is so great about
it probably the bishop of course doesn't
belong on G5 it could very easily get
attacked by the queen and yeah he
probably doesn't care about it just okay
but now I kind of don't think that's a
thing I don't think
that that's
possible okay let's
see okay so he goes back uh and we
probably should Castle Queen side but it
could be it could be dangerous he does
have the semi-open B
file uh but yeah let's uh make it
interesting let's make it
interesting yeah D5 of course uh with
some C5 uh in the future uh we're going
to advance it to uh to E5 he's going to
go back and now we even sacrifice a pawn
here yeah but not this one obviously as
our F Pawn is hanging that's the problem
otherwise I would do
it h yeah now I'm kind of intrigued uh
by this uh
possibility yeah again
I'm
very interesting
indeed
H yeah I don't I don't see anything
better I don't see anything better I
probably should have just played that
instantly but what are you going to
do what are you going to do let's
continue
our our adventures on the king side he
now will play something like Rook B8 he
will go uh Pawn to C5 and so on and so
on and uh I will have to set up some
sort of a defensive perimeter
here uh but also I will just push the H
Pawn since I don't know this setup all
that well probably the Knight will come
to C5 at some point no he goes for mate
right away which
uh yeah of course which I can't block
all that
well uh but yeah let's see let's see
what he what he
has okay he has that yeah Okay so we've
pretty much blundered everything we
could this game uh and now it's merely a
matter of how to how to make it
interesting for
him
okay
our opponent really really destroying us
here but okay we will we will get to see
either get to see his execution or maybe
we can we can make it uh very very
difficult for him so we'll see what he
does and uh yeah I will I will make a
special memo to to improve uh at least
something on the on the pawn to E
Sicilian uh not a lot I know about
that so what are some of the good moves
that he could play pretty much all of
them every anything he plays here is a
good move like even Knight to C4 is
probably a good move uh
so probably this also gets to free up
his uh Bishop here which is very
nice D4 probably also good he can
probably just he play and play A5 this
like everything is a good move here this
is a good move yeah he goes for it he
goes for it of
course why wouldn't
he for the moment there's no threat here
but he does get to come here which can
be very annoying he does get to maybe
come here which also can be very
annoying and I don't want to trade that
uh that's
uh something I don't want to
do
yeah okay let's go
here yeah he does have the immediate E5
but uh we're going to block it so for
the moment I don't think it's super
relevant yeah if he moves the queen from
this diagonal we might have some
pressure on his Rook not right away
because it doesn't do anything but maybe
it it can become relevant in some lines
so we'll see what it does uh probably no
he goes for the check right away he goes
for the check right away as he should
yeah
h
I have to find at least something tricky
for him to to sink his teeth in
otherwise I can just resign this uh but
we are we are making this the series to
try and be resilient as
possible yeah I can also just remove the
defender of my Bishop yeah there's a
when your position is this good uh
literally every move is a winning
move literally every move is a winning
move so if this was a serious game or
you know if I was just playing for um
for myself this is resigns territory but
since we are we are doing this sort of
the to see what what moves can be done
in in uh what position and also to sort
of force my opponent to prove his point
and to win the game uh with precise
moves we are going to continue it all
right so he uh let's get our yeah so now
this is coming so let's uh make it a as
annoying for him as possible go
here yeah if he goes here we can even
get our Knight into the game that would
actually maybe give me some hopes of uh
not not of gaining any sort of a
position but of of actually being able
to make a
move yeah he he completely destroyed us
here so what what does he want now okay
now now he actually is attacking the
Knight it's the problem yeah we have to
go
here no no other way to do
it he will give a check and then play E5
I think I think that's that's good for
him get a check I will play King here
and he will will play E5 and I'll play
G4 because I've got nothing better and
he will play
E4 and
uh yeah we're going to go for G4
here we're finding some unique moves
here to keep us in the game but we're
not really in the game make no mistake
here this is dead lost this is like uh
if you if you allow the engine to Crunch
the numbers here it would say probably
minus 34 for for
black yeah okay so he goes for E4 right
away we have to move with
Tempo
uh he can pretty much do anything
probably he will go for Queen F2 just to
remain remain present and to be as
annoying as possible or if he doesn't
want to see Rook F1 he might even go
Queen to C5 even that that's not no he
goes Queen B6
actually yeah that's uh great we're just
going to push the pawn because we we've
got nothing better we've got nothing
better than to push the
pawn and uh he will of course stop it he
does not want to see H6 on the board if
he allows H6 then that's already
dangerous
territory not that not that I have
anything but at least uh no he actually
allows
it I I I didn't think he
would very
interesting
yeah okay I mean I've got nothing better
here he can even push he doesn't even
have to capture pushing is is incredibly
strong
here now he will play it this way very
interesting okay
so how do we how do we expand here on
this
go Knight here the Knight isn't doing
anything for the moment
here play Queen B4 probably or queen to
C7 Queen C7 doesn't do all that much
yeah now we're
already within within interesting
territory
H let's go
here
he will push her capture but uh like I
said I've got nothing
better I've got nothing
better and we sort of have a thread of
Rook captus here but it's a long shot
it's a really a long shot and also if he
moves the queen we do have Checkmate but
that's never going to happen uh we maybe
can get our Knight somewhere but after
the Knight comes to C5 his light Square
Bishop controls everything so it's not
that
spectacular uh still like I said the
position is so good for him that he can
pretty much play anything he can give up
any amount of Pawns here and still be
winning uh but we will we will try to
make it as unpleasant for him as
possible yeah so if he by some miracle
blunders and allows Rook captures on D5
then maybe we can achieve something but
still I don't think we can I don't think
we
can yeah he he does he would open up
this diagonal so that would be pretty
pretty
huge but at least now he's uh
considering
stuff yeah okay so he he spots
it he spots it and he allows me to
capture this but that will will sort of
get all of his pieces into the game and
I will never be in time to play Bishop
here so that's uh kind of his
point but I don't think I have anything
better than than to actually go for
it yeah I don't think I
do uh no I'm not going to no he wants to
play this he wants to trade Queens he
wants to trade Queens sneaky sneaky guy
play
G5 sneaky sneaky guy yeah now he's just
going to push now he's just going to
push but at least now that we get our
Knight to C5 we are controlling the
squares of the bishop yeah it's very
annoying very annoying I have no idea
what to make of this because he has so
many good moves it's very hard for him
to just choose
one
ah yeah I'm guessing it's uh I'm
guessing it's always best
to yeah I don't have anything better I
just have to capture and uh that's
it and the rest is
history
yeah I've got nothing better I've got
nothing
better
so so hard to to to to find anything
here but maybe
maybe
yeah maybe he gives us a little bit at
least
something yeah okay so uh he goes after
the Knight as he should the Knight can
be a pretty dangerous piece here
uh and also it's going to be a free
piece if I capture because the the B
Pawn is pinned so kind of
annoying so we have to play
this and now he has to be a little bit
careful because Rook captures is an
option Queen captures and Bishop to C4
sort of scures his
Queen but I don't think we get that far
I don't think we get that far still we
are making it annoying for him move by
move
maybe maybe an opportunity presents
itself no he will go for this of course
yeah let's go all the way
back all the way
back yeah we have to now now just E3 and
I think that's game for
him if he plays E3 I think we resign
here yeah he's going to do it of course
he's going to do it and we have to move
yeah not not a lot to be done
here
yeah we have to take it we have to take
it no other
way he he'll play E2 of course he
doesn't need to even be bothered with
this
maybe yeah he he has everything under
control yeah E2 is such a beautiful move
for
him such a great move for
him yeah now if I capture he will just
uh capture and if I capture here he will
capture here I will capture here and he
picks up my knight because the B Pawn is
pinned and that's all there is that
that's all there
[Music]
is probably goes for that
that now there's there's no way to gain
any sort of access to G7 I'm hoping
there would be but there isn't yeah now
just one check and that's it one check
and it's game
over yep that's the
stuff that's the
stuff even just bring a uh give a check
and bring a second Queen into the game
and he doesn't have to be worried about
no he's going to capture here I'll sort
of allow me
to to nothing yeah there's nothing we
can try here we can give a check but
it's not
much here we have to take here and and
he plays Rook here no yeah he plays
Rooks here and that's pretty much
it that's pretty much
it yeah good game good game Mr cppy 48
we we tried making it as uh unpleasant
as possible but it was not enough good
game and now for the for the actual fun
part let's see what we what we missed
here uh we we missed pretty much
everything but what was what was
something that we actually played okay
so D4 all right pretty standard stuff
Knight C3 Knight C6 Bishop to E2 uh
capturing sort of the main line here
yeah that's the yeah B6 and D5 yeah but
uh this is you have to know how to play
it if if you want to play something like
this E5 Knight to D5 and not Knight to
E4 that's sort of the tricky way to play
I play this maybe a bit passively Bishop
E2 but still should be fine uh yeah and
he should have played immediate D5
okay still can be played okay so on D5
H4 right away uh prevented this uh
liberating maneuver I played F4 Queen G3
yeah the move we were considering also
possible Rook B8 I played H4 and already
after Queen to B4 uh objectively we are
lost because he uh connected it nicely
with with the thread of Checkmate and
this F4 Pawn Yeah
and now the the rest is history but we
can simply we can check if there was
anything any maybe poison in the
position that we missed or maybe he had
some sort of a brilliant mate in in in
in three or four as I'm pretty sure he
did uh but yeah okay he went this we
went this way he allowed H6 okay nothing
spectacular nothing nothing to hope for
here played Queen F7 G5 F4 and uh yeah
that's all there is to it yeah the
engine of course just wants to make it
as simple as possible uh we tried uh we
tried our best but in the end uh yeah it
it wasn't possible but again like I said
I'm making these videos to to show you
guys what to consider in any position
not just to get like a winning position
out of the opening and then crush your
opponent as this game we did get a a
fairly strong opponent 2419 is no
Child's Play and uh yeah he he got got
got his way with us right out of the
opening and he continued pushing um till
the end of the game but uh you've seen
what what you can try he saw through
everything he stopped all of my ideas uh
yeah basically the only thing he had to
do after I played H6 and G5 was to keep
G7 Square uh sort of safe uh and he he
spotted that trick where I tried to to
capture his Queen and basically aside
from those two things there was not all
that much to worry about but he still
had to play precise moves and he had to
figure out a way on how to win the game
and that was by pushing his uh extra
points in theer center of the board was
the cleanest way to do it definitely uh
so yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it uh and uh uh hope hopefully
you were able to take something from
this game and maybe use it in your own
games um to crush your opponents like um
copy 48 crushed me uh so once again hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check to
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day